okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about code
assistance helping people to write
correct code more easily so we are
looking I think at some UX for code
assistance is that right yeah so at
first the first item is going to be kind
of fast quick I think going oh we're
going to talk about the code format so
that's really exciting that's why I put
that second but yeah no just first
things first okay
let's we see your screen yeah yeah yeah
sure okay go for it so we want to add a
menu item by the way do we have somebody
from design here Jeremy's here okay okay
great
so we're wanting to add a menu item to
the evaluation menu I'm thinking
underneath here in beach right where
this delimiter is what's he to say
analyze notebook that will do this
functionality so look over in the code
assistance demo notebook and then when I
evaluate this you see that all of the
little problem balloons pop up you know
independent of doing any shift in or
evaluations it's cool and so just adding
this obviously first probably to the
prototype build and let people let
people discover it and figure out like
what's going on but well you know I mean
all this menu is ridiculously
complicated and yeah yeah I think we
should put a bunch of sub menus in here
I mean for example you know I mean I
think all the kernel could the parallel
kernel stuff and so on yeah I mean
there's a bunch of sub menus clearly the
debugger nobody uses that at this point
I don't even know if it still works does
it it still works
I get bugs on it okay well that's a good
sign that people are using it
I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't assume
that nobody's using it and I would say
that some of that usage is a bit
frustrated but people are still trying
right well hopefully this whole approach
will be a better path forward but yeah
okay look I don't
this menu this menu needs to be clean it
needs to be cleaned up but putting
analyze notebook well how about analyze
code in notebook you mean just for the
tech yeah I mean sure that'd be fine it
was just a question of analyzing the
entire notebook or do we want to analyze
whatever selected cells that you have
and just in the name of you know brevity
and just having one menu item doing the
entire notebook makes the most sense
yeah analyze could a notebook I think
otherwise it's obscure what this
actually means I'm not completely
certain this is the right menu for it
you mean the entire category the
evaluation menu you know look at the
Edit menu I mean yes you're right
because a value even having it in the
evaluation menu does still even connote
evaluation is happening when you know
this this is supposed to be why don't
you put some thing but it's not an
editing operation
well no it's check spelling well check
spelling is pretty close this is check
code which is well I think it should be
called if we're thinking about generally
organizing the whole menu structure
there is a cell category here has have
people ever wanted a notebook menu
capitals there used to be one in version
one I think there was a notebook
top-level category it has it has to be
version one because I've never seen it
and I've been working since
version 2.1 so unless I'm crazy we could
look at a bit in one screenshot I'm
pretty sure there was a notebook menu
um someone else I'll have to share their
screen for that yeah I know think we
could shy don't exhume works on a Mac
you know SC 30 or something but if we
think about maybe a notebook top level
menu category not sure I think solo from
that mmm no I don't think so
yeah I mean what do you think about
having it be in the cell menu I don't
think it makes any sense okay where do
you think it should go well I mean I had
started with the evaluation menu because
it's very much a situation this is still
a you know an early thing right so I
think some of our live stream is
suggesting analyze well what I would do
is say analyze code in or analyze code
in selection would be something in the
right-click menu yeah
separately yes all right all right in
the evaluation notebook let's see it
again please just the menu here oh yeah
see these are so I would put it if
you're gonna put it somewhere here if
there was any other way to pull up the
debugger I would take it out of this
menu and use that space for this
function functionality yeah well the one
weird thing about the organization here
is it is a bit strange that there's you
know debugger by itself and then
debugger controls I mean we could move
everything into a submenu sure and that
would not be unsensible in my opinion
fine but then still if we say analyze
code and then
says debugger it gives the debugger more
importance we really want to bury the
debugger I'll tell you what I'll tell
you what how about we put under find
currently evaluating cell it's kind of
like an abort he thing the debugger we
could put the debugger underneath there
kind of hide it in that group and say
debugger dot dot in there and then put
the menu items associated with this code
analysis up in that slot where we've got
the debugger right now it won't be dot
dot dot one menu item a triangle yeah
yeah I'm yeah I mean you say debugger
dot dot dot dot that dot implies that it
invokes an interface okay if I'm fine
I'm SP bugger you know aero-sub ma'am
yeah um okay yeah okay
let's put it that it's not a great place
for it because it's sandwiched in
between a bunch of things that are
really about evaluation humph
so I am on our live stream is suggesting
splitting some of the items and
evaluation into tools tools would be an
interesting menu to have I agree that
would be an interesting menu so we
definitely don't want a notebook top
level we're not gonna have a notebook
top level menus no no but why okay
because we've already got file exactly
and you should know that Stephen and I
come to blows on user interface stuff
all the time so when we're time we agree
in agreement yeah okay let's look at the
file menu for a second
is this 12.1 I guess it is yeah yeah you
know an interesting possibility will be
an analyze thing here or analyze file or
something like just to analyze yeah it's
I mean it's although it operates on a
whole notebook in a fundamental sense
it's not a file level operation I mean
the I won't be in the future I agree
with that yeah well I I mean for example
if you save close and reopen the
notebook you won't see these annotations
at least not as presently designed which
i think is the right thing I think it's
the right thing all right let's put it
for now on the evaluation menu so it
goes back to the evaluation menu let's
move debugger underneath those fine
currently evaluating cell and let's put
it it's very own section analyze code in
notebook and hopefully that will give it
you know such bright lights that people
will pay attention to it and basically
you mean putting it in that section yes
this group yeah yes yes for now I think
it may end up being mostly actually I
would suggest that rather than putting
it there I would put it above the
dynamic stuff fine because because it's
really quite closely related to
evaluation
you know the dynamic is a form of
evaluation but a different form what
fine fine fine fine then put put it
maybe without even a break under
evaluate initialization cells and then
analyze code in notebook it's a third
item in that section yeah okay all right
let's let's let's now now that we've
done some throat clearing and don't
forget the right-click menu analyze code
in selection yeah okay now let's
actually look at the content please
because that's the main event yes
now are we going to have a function as
well yeah I mean it necessarily has to
call into the kernel regardless so
yeah are you meaning to analyze ink it
should be called notebook code analysis
or something no that doesn't suggest
let's see well so there's a question
here what the function does I mean if
the you know does the function just
programmatically create what we're
seeing here that's straightforward it's
maybe not as useful
what's more useful maybe but but
something that I'm not sure if we have a
pattern for is something that can like
generator reports well we do have a
patent for that we have plenty of
patents like the notebook templating
stuff like generate document generate
document is a perfect example
no no I don't think so hey sorry sorry
when I say I I may have misspoken a bit
when I said generate a report I mean
what what I meant was something which
programmatically returns you know what
are the errors that came up in which
cells were they attached to uh well that
will be similar to the testing framework
for example may be similar to what the
testing framework should be doing I'm
not sure if it's the same as what it's
actually doing yeah just so people also
know there are reporting functions that
already exist but just not for notebook
but but so what I mean here for example
is that you want to be able to you know
as some kind of schedule task or
something you want to be able to run an
analysis on a book and report that the
analysis was clean or if it wasn't clean
you know here are the things that came
out of the analysis right in other words
you like on the function repository you
might just run this on everything yeah
okay so listen I think there's a there's
a language design thing and let's get
that separately okay can you make a list
of all the functions like your lint
string reports and so on all these other
ones and let's do a session doing
language design on these but let's not
do that today yeah I think that's
probably a good idea let's let's go look
at your right hand side here and what
it's actually doing because that's a
little different that's not what weird
is that what we agreed last time in
terms of the UX you know this is old UX
not current it is what is currently
implemented though okay but you've got
the new UX right yes I mean it's it's in
you know we have the meetings and we
discussed the design and we're figuring
out how to put the Chevron's and how to
put the squigglies and all of that yeah
yeah okay do you have something you have
a design document you should be this
flash up over that well no not right now
because I wasn't planning on doing this
this is just old this is just the older
so we were mostly just talking about
whether my new item yes okay but so then
your your task
though is to implement the new
squigglies and Chevron's and all that
kind of stuff right now some of that
stuff is gonna have to be in the front
end ya know there it's a lot of
front-end work also that I you know here
can we see the design do you have a
design document has is there a designer
who's worked on the design it was it
Billy had worked on a design document
for this it was him but he's out so I
don't have access to his files and I'm
not sure I'll be able fine let's go on
to the next segment then so I think
there's nothing more to say about that I
mean you know that I'm really looking
forward to that UX because I think it's
wonderful
oh yeah yeah yeah um and obviously that
you actually go back into things like um
the UM um yeah by the way that Brian and
I are live stream is agreeing with me
that the word code needs to be in the
name of these things it's not notebook
analyzed because there's all kinds of
random stuff in a notebook it's code
analysis notebook code analysis right
that's that's what it needs to say yeah
when it's now caught yeah makes the
naming of the functions if you want
no I I don't know that's right let's not
do the function naming now okay no and
it should be in anyway um I mean all
permutations uh don't worry about that
okay it's not relevant right now okay
just bring all those to the meeting
where we're going to talk about language
design for these please okay okay
let's let's go back all right now let's
go on with the section two which was
code formatting so okay the way of a
deep breath
new topic very exciting okay on we go
yeah so yeah we've had a few meetings
but for the benefit of everyone you know
watching and listening we've been
discussing code formatting and there
have been a few different approaches
that I've been looking at and exploring
people even at the tech conference we're
asking about it and we've been able to
say we're actively working on it and
anyway so the main thing you're gonna
show is the white space and new line
changer is that correct yeah yeah which
is which we think is a valuable okay so
let's let's okay so we talked about
airiness level the extent to which new
lines just get added well not just new
lines but okay so I want to I want to
manage expectations right here airiness
level and its full glory is not going to
be shown today because I'm still working
on things but there is a minuscule
smaller version of just showing what is
possible with different levels of white
space and new lines and what I've been
working on mainly is within a single lot
or within a single expression I should
say that might span lines what what you
can do by adding white space in between
things okay let's see not even only
always adding new lines but also
sometimes removing them so I can I made
up a little manipulate here
so this is the string from above so just
imagine that this is just normal
I understand and so there are these very
weird code but yeah go ahead
to be sure for everyone this is
demonstration code yes no I understand
but I'd like to see it with a real piece
of code because presumably this your
code runs on anything this is just okay
so so you're gonna run it on this and
then we're gonna run on some real piece
of code yep and so what you can just try
try moving the slider you try moving the
slider so we can actually see what so
it's the formatting is not on and so
just simply formatting it with the
lowest setting possible you can see so
what ends up happening is some basic
things change where the line
continuations disappear yeah okay so
that's how genetic formatting and you
can see I get it yeah okay that's the
generic formatting I understand so now
let's see what happens when you change
that okay so if you go down to the
middle the first that I consider the
next change that I think is acceptable
to people is adding a space when there
is implicit times and so if you see the
contiguous and I see it I see it yeah
yes and the next one is below where you
there are cases where yeah I see it
those are nice okay continue and then
the whole thing I don't think that's
interesting the whole thing wets but
it's really Airy like that I couldn't
care less about that I would say that
the the thing that you're showing
previously is stuff that should be
default formatting that is if you move
that back to about a third of the way
across the Arias thing you know the fact
that for blanks format you just type in
for blanks together just type in
someplace oh yeah so that doesn't do
that yeah there is I mean there is an
understanding in the front end about
yeah so what was the y-you I mean that's
fine and what about this isn't for code
that's in notebooks
what are you talking about but that's
what happens in a notebook right but
what I'm talking about this is this code
being in a dot M file that someone
formats where oh well I mean yes putting
in a bunch of I mean yes I mean that
will be the minimal thing to do is put
in a bunch of the the auto spacing rules
that we already have why not what wait a
second
the why not is because this is supposed
to be a plain text is it a plain text
file or is it not a plain text file yeah
plain text okay but if it's a text file
hold on if it's a plain text file you
get to put in one space or zero spaces
and not a thin space right so in the
front end that's undoubtedly a thin
space right say I think it's larger than
a thin space but smaller than a real
space yeah right yeah but but Brenton
what are you doing exactly here because
in this demo is this plain text is this
a string don't get hung up on the you
know the underscore specifically no no I
I know that I just want to know is it
plain text yeah okay so so when you move
that airiness thing between the FF
bracket and G bracket it is adding a
space a literal a literal stress okay as
ASCII 32 yes okay and so yeah a lot of
this is obviated by working in the front
end obviously but you know well even in
the front end we are highly interested
to know about newline airiness right
even in the front end it is my belief
well there are cases where it's very
relevant the front end like in code
cells for example code cells have no
space lots of Auto spacing doesn't
happen in code cells well okay but fun
but the let's let's command eight just
type it's just copy just copy your
source into that no no done well
that that okay but just copy that source
into the code cell oh for God's sake are
you serious that's not gonna work that's
not gonna work in this Oh what did that
just do I I'm not sure about the
formatting inside of manipulate I see
okay okay so that's the code cell
version of this is that is that got all
this pen and the I don't know where the
there oh oh it's double the backslash is
because it was inside a string so yeah
remove one from the yep
okay we did leave some auto
multiplication stuff in here arguably
maybe we shouldn't have I think I think
reasonable people might might disagree
on that one oh I think look there's
nothing wrong with so long as it's clear
what's actually gonna be there in the
plain text file all is fair I think in
these code cells and in fact my argument
is I mean I'm not a big fan of the fact
that code cells don't do any Auto
formatting but whatever I mean I never
use them for that reason never use them
some people man but you have to
understand I mean you personally have to
understand that some people use them for
that reason I know that I know but but
okay I want to come back to what I see
is the main point of airiness which is
line breaking the eyes both to auto
formatted code in the front end in an
ordinary cell in an ordinary input cell
for example and to you know what we
might call integer broken you know
plaintext code well a lot of times it
will make well the the spaces will make
less sense in an input cell the new
lines a lot of sense
yeah the new lines are what we care
about an input cell that was the whole
point and I mean I think that in in an
input cell we can imagine having you
know continuous
variations of line spacing as well we
can consider having you know in addition
to a paragraph break you know we can
have phrases and the sudden the other we
can have a a mini paragraph break so to
speak if you understand what I'm saying
in the code which is a degree of freedom
that we don't have I mean right here we
have double new lines which is a useful
degree of freedom in kind of plain text
formatted code but we may have an
intermediate case
in a sort of Auto formatted code not I
shouldn't say Waterboys it what should I
say notebook formatted code um okay I
mean this is fine as far as it goes a
bit but okay so what did we really want
to look at here I mean this is fine but
the thing that I think is really
interesting is the new line case because
I think that's what's going to move the
needle in terms of making code
absolutely in it it's just in flux there
are there are issues involved with
knowing you know because you can't just
add a new line right right there's there
were just lots of issues so one you want
to reproduce any indentation that you
might have
Yoram above you know or maybe you don't
because what you're doing is correcting
the indentation that you're already you
know that you're working with right oh
you want to make one's additional
indentation if you're indenting within a
sub you know subtree and so on yeah yeah
I guess I mean the indentation I
understand if you've got indentation n
already on a line and you decide to
break that line you probably want at
least indentation n if not indentation n
plus something yeah yeah I just mean
even before considering adding my
another you might want to remove
indentation cuz it's wrong
yes yeah and so you don't have any
questions how much signaling did the
fact that somebody put indentation in
you don't just want to blow away their
indentation because they may have some
beautiful indentation correct yes you
know the thing that is very meaningful
to their code the question is how do you
tell so this is a heuristic we need how
do you tell that somebody just goofed
the indentation
yes that is yeah yeah okay so let me
give you some suggested heuristics okay
so let's think about how it got there
okay so if for example somebody started
editing and they just started typing
without typing any tabs are these tabs
that indentation do we expecting are we
expecting their space indentation I mean
the answers yes to anything yeah all
right so then they may not even be
consistent in the same body of code fine
yeah which is unfortunate and makes
Brenton's job a heck of a lot more
difficult okay let me make a couple of
suggestions about that do we want to
actually merge how many how many spaces
is a tablet is it four it's anything
that the user thought it was when he was
writing it but it does something
definite in the text editor what does it
do in a typical text editor well it's
that you can change yeah four is more
common than anything else but when I say
more common I don't mean 98% I mean like
maybe like maybe 55 percents okay all
right okay but so so there's quite a bit
of division on this okay so what we know
at the beginning of a line is it's n
tabs and M spaces but actually it isn't
just that it's a sequence of yasin
spaces right because the tabs might have
been aligned yes
hold on by the way in additionally there
are some editors that are you know
there's some for matters that don't just
align things on tab stops whether by
tabs or spaces so for example you might
want to line up the inside of a comment
and the inside of the comments might not
have been on a tab stop so you just have
to add extra spaces that don't
correspond to a tab stop at all okay I
understand
but all of these things assume
monospaced fonts without monospaced
fonts everybody is toast does that
yes yes correct okay all right and is
that a good assumption in the world
today if I absolutely do not want to
deal with them no I'm asking it is a
good assumption in the world today yes
okay
all right fine it's interesting how
that's evolved um okay so so then one of
the questions is what's the heuristic
given that what you see so what you've
got is a bunch of lines that have random
sequences of tabs and spaces you know
you could probably heuristic aliy deduce
where the tab stops where the person
thought the tab stops were by looking at
the correspondence between spaces and
tabs on similar lines yeah yeah yeah
right so but the overarching thing so we
don't even know whether what we think it
looks like is what it actually looked
like because the tabs what determines so
the tab stops are typically every four
characters is that correct but they are
tab stops as in they go like an old
typewriter to that position right so
that's even that I'm gonna say is you
know four is more common than anything
else but it's it's difficult to say
anything Universal here but but I mean
is it a snap grid or is it it's not just
you put in four four spaces it's it
snaps to a granularity for anything
you're I mean it just yes yes yes if you
press if you are in an editor where tabs
or spaces then pressing a tab takes you
to the next multiple of four that is
your question yes that's what I'm saying
yes okay so first point it is almost
certainly deducible if there is a single
parameter let's call it we could call it
something very scientific like Tao the
towel the tab stop you know the tab stop
parameter okay it is very likely we can
deduce what Tao is from looking at a
piece from looking at a file
let's assume that we know the value of
tau or worst case the user could tell us
but but let's assume we know it then the
question is when did the user goof well
first of all what canonicalization do we
want to do on there so for example let's
say that we know the value of tau and
it's 4 okay
and we see certain lines that have you
know 7 spaces in a tab do we want to
replace that by just 2 tabs I think
possibly yes I think that's a civilized
thing to do am I making sense yeah yes
I'm a bit worried though that trying to
figure out the heuristics and applying
them it the you know based on context
maybe a lot of time spent on an
ultimately losing game all right well
okay fine but whereas the the other
possibility that I would pose is you
know making it easy for users to
configure whatever they want fine let's
do this let's put in the parameter tau
as a user configurable thing yeah and
let's the
you
and let's some later on figure out
whether we can deduce Tao you know
machine learning Li okay
I predict that we will be able to but we
don't need to cross that bridge we can
you know generically set it to four or
whatever and then the user can reset it
with some UX which we do not know yet no
like we could indicate tab stops or
something and people could just move it
I don't know how not sure how I'm sure
editors have a way of specifying that
okay but that doesn't solve the problem
of when when was a line a goof right
when was it meaning for versus when was
it a goof okay so for example an example
of something that might be a goof is
something where like I've done this you
know there's some beautifully tab thing
which I don't understand at all because
I opened it an editor that has different
tab stops no tab stops at all you know I
opened it in the front end I opened it
somewhere where where all the stuff was
crazy and I want to add some lines and I
just start typing and my lines go in on
the left margin because and you know I
press some some tabs and it zooms often
up to wherever because it you know the
tab stops were different yeah so clearly
in a case like that where it's a I just
started typing a line I think
I gave no okay so one cases I gave no
indentation I think in that case it is
reasonable unless there are lots of
lines with no indentation around it to
assume that I meant to give indentation
that corresponds to the the ambient
indentation assuming that it is in a
semantic group with that ambient
indentation you know if it's a if it's a
separated comment or something I might
have wanted to outdent it that making
sense yeah the problem is ambient
indentation sometimes is only maybe one
just the line above it or the line below
it and you don't actually have that much
context so what so what I mean look what
I'm saying is okay look you have two
pieces of information you know where it
is semantically in the code right yep
okay so semantically this line that got
added that had no indentation given to
it should have Auto indented to
something okay now the question is if it
is semantically the same thing if it's a
list for example and you know it broke
you know the list was broken you know
twice above it and it went to a certain
indent level when the list broke and now
we've got some elements added which were
unand nted okay then we know those
elements being added are of the same
semantic level as the other elements in
the list
therefore it is reasonable to indent
them the same as the other things on the
list yes right okay so that's one case
one case is it is at the same semantic
level as the thing that began the
proceeding or line or the next line I
would argue if it's at the sum if you
know if the user showed intent for
indentation of something of the same
semantic level nearby then you know what
the indentation should be if you believe
that the indentation of the line you're
looking at was in error
so one question is you've got three
lines they've all got different
indentation which one is right okay
that's another question
on this on this meeting who might um um
I might help in is by the way we have a
couple of UX comments on the live stream
here one is somebody who always wanted
sell drag-and-drop yeah that would be
cool wouldn't it why do we never
consider that John I think we were so
put off drag and drop by some of the
things that happened about a decade or
15 years ago with them what was it what
what is that we did have selection
drag-and-drop for a while oh that's
right and that was horrifying yeah but
we never had sell drag-and-drop it's a
little unclear to me how you the III
would be concerned that it would be
invoked when you were trying to do
selection too often yeah possibly
I mean look selection drag-and-drop was
disastrous I mean did they take that out
of the main line word processors now uh
I haven't been bitten by it in a while
it's either been taken out or it's
harder to access yeah I don't remember
if it's harder than no it's no I her
does he know the answer to that anybody
no no okay
it can I'm in land looking at word under
windows and it does work there
apparently the Jupiter people have
implemented sell drag-and-drop which may
or may not be an advertisement for it
um anyway it's probably worth looking at
sell drag and drop again keyboard
navigation up and down the cell
hierarchy would be nice we do have
keyboard navigation but what happens
that's a bit unfortunate is that it's
very easy to drop out of a cell
selection into a so insertion point and
then you can get back into cell
insertion selection if you actually drop
out from the keyboard but a lot of
people don't know how to do it unless
what you're saying what when you've got
into a cell insertion point the question
is how do you know it's gonna you know
do a text selection now if you press
shift up arrow it will select a cell but
a lot of people don't know I didn't know
that been like that 30 years and I still
didn't know it also the other thing is
that you might expect left and right
arrow to push in and out in a cell group
that does not happen maybe it should I
don't see why not
I mean we've also got that navigation
for you know mobile we've got a separate
set of cell navigation things and it
would be nice to have them correspond
III I think one of the reasons we never
got around in doing this is control
period or command period you know does
push out in cell groups and we had
always thought that we would get around
to implementing the shift version of
that which would you know dive back in
word I didn't even know that come on
period went up went out in cell groups a
community goes out everywhere where it's
possible to go yeah I mean I I'm yes
there's a side from the notebook
itself the only thing that can stop a
command period is an input field because
input fields are made to contain
selections yeah there's another comment
that sort of interesting send a saying
he'd like cell brackets on the left I
believe that in version one we had the
choice of cell brackets on the left or
the right
so brackets well and you know if you
have a right to left language then cell
brackets on the left are awesome but the
the principle we should we have a set do
we have a setting to put them on the
left no the principal issue with cell
brackets on the left is that it forces
either variable left margins or lots of
space on things up yeah that was that
was why we took it out of version one
yeah yep but I mean that presumably is a
way to do that by having particularly if
you have you know if you have a fixed
width channel there and you just like we
can have invisible cell brackets no if
you're willing not to show all of the
grouping then to have the grouping get
clipped in some form then yes that could
be done or moving to the I mean it's
scrolling that's a little bit weird
scrolling within the grouping I don't
think people would figure that out yeah
okay um all right let's come back though
to the but actually actually one more
thing on this comment though is it's
it's sometimes hard to see where the
code on the left aligns to the cell
bracket that's a problem we can fix by
means other than moving the cell
brackets to the left I know we in the
you know and that sort of thing we
should have a hover effect in the show
and we frequently talked about it we
just haven't done it um and I I think I
I think actually a hover effect and a
selection effect that you know we should
do that I still wish cloud the cloud had
done that at one point
well then while the cloud had done a
hover effect but I think that both a
hover effect an ax selection effects are
honestly I think those are important and
I think we should look at that okay
separate from this meeting but those
that that could be the most important
thing that came out of this specific
meeting I agree that those should be
proud that on is really important stuff
is very important I agree the specifics
of of quadruple blank are probably not
the most important example of Brent and
stuff that comes up more often than you
think okay I'm only sure the grouping
beyond a certain level until the cursor
enters the bracket range
well yeah but but you can't you could I
don't see how you do that there just
isn't space on the left to put
additional brackets anyway I mean
there's probably some something that can
be thought about about brackets on the
left but I think I agree with you John
that I think this thing about hover
effect is the obvious thing to do and we
should do it yeah I mean it's a you know
I disagree with the remedy but I agree
with the problem the problem being that
you know you want to see how things line
up and know right I mean even just some
effect that doesn't have to be
highlighting the whole cell but some
effect as you enter the cell that don't
we have that in the cloud that shows
that highlights the cell bracket it does
in the cloud it does highlight something
because it shows you the gear menu right
when you're over that cell it's showing
you so yeah but that's that's I think to
settle I agree but something like that
or some lines above and below the cell
or something like that when you're when
you enter the zone of the cell I don't
think you want to change the background
color of the cell because that makes big
mess for other purposes um okay but
anyway let's come back to the heuristics
of tabs and spaces okay
so everything so I guess it could be
boiled down to the problem is simply
knowing when yeah the user goofed the
the formatting okay so the first
question is what actions can you take
okay so let's talk about some actions
you could take and I hope somebody is
okay
you could merge spaces and tabs that's
one action you can take may be a good
idea may be a bad idea I don't know okay
you can decide the user was clueless and
just indent for them yes okay which is
easy easy too yes yeah yeah okay
you can decide the user was trying to
tell one something by their indentation
and then try and just add some
consistency or you could say the user is
is it's brilliant and knows exactly what
they want to do and I don't want to
touch it um so the question is okay one
question would be can we effectively I
mean this feels like one of these sort
of typical machine learning things can
we learn enough about the user what the
users conventions are supposed to be
that we can extrapolate from them well I
mean one difficult sort of problem that
comes up around that is what if when I'm
looking at isn't my code and it's not
obvious if it's not my code what I might
want to do with it I mean maybe maybe
I'm working as somebody else's git repo
and I want to stick to their conventions
or maybe uh you know I'm putting the you
know I'm putting this code in my own
stuff and I want it in my style not
their style no that is a good point okay
so look to me okay so first question is
can we learn the parameters of
somebody's style answer probably yes and
probably not without without that many
examples actually so you know and and
the style will be basically I mean we
need to parameterize the style like how
much
denting where do they end en't how what
is their propensity to line-break those
kinds of things assume there are dozen
parameters that characterize somebody's
style assume we could learn them okay
from a piece of code from code that they
have assumed that we could fill in those
parameters for a piece of code where we
say well you've mostly followed your own
conventions but you've made a few you
know things that don't follow your
conventions we're going to ignore those
somehow okay sure I mean I don't know
what the UX of this is gonna look like
but I kind of think that there may be um
I mean okay so here's a crazy idea for
you assume that we could make kind of a
mini map type picture of code where we
have sort of a standardized piece of
code and we show what it would look like
in various conventions okay and assume
that that what we do is we could deduce
from a user's sample the code I mean
somebody could do this for themselves
they could run a piece of code that says
take these examples of mine and make my
personal mini map of what my indentation
style is and so on and then that becomes
essentially a tile a button that they
could press along with others that so in
other words imagine that because I think
it's impossible to describe you know
it's ridiculous okay
airiness maybe one parameter but even
you know even that it may be that the
better thing to do is to show them like
a visual gallery of you know code
appearances including maybe one that
they have custom it's like a custom font
that you made for yourself or something
you know I've tried to do that for
myself multiple times over the years
I've never found one that actually works
properly from handwriting especially as
my handwriting is getting worse and
worse but that's a separate issue there
nobody but more seriously the um
what do people think of that idea of
kind of a visual gallery of indent a of
formatting styles that you could pick
from just to know what the target is
so other systems do have a way I know
Eclipse has something lots of other
editors have this kind of system for
displaying what you have a check list of
checkboxes or you know setters whatever
the parameters are and as you're
changing them it updates this canonical
piece of code to show you what it's
doing I'm in fun book so this is a
better version of that I think yeah well
I mean if it if people if people know
what they want
then I'm selling a bunch of checkboxes
is a is a poor person's way of saying
this is code I like set the parameters
like this right if we can do that it's
better than having a bunch of checkboxes
I wonder what fraction of the time
people I mean maybe people set those
checkboxes I have no idea but you know
obviously if we have a set of parameters
people can set the parameters we don't
necessarily have to provide them a big
UX we could just have a language level
thing that's somebody could build the UX
if they really want to um but I mean if
the okay but the whole point here is
that there is a concept that there is a
target
right there's a target of what you want
the code roughly to look like from a
distance so to speak
right yeah yeah because that's not
obvious that's not obvious I mean that
John's point is obviously correct that
you don't know whether it's your code or
somebody else's code um and by default
it might be set to be you know the tile
that is deduced from your own code or we
might have a default default default
that we can all argue about
okay but then the question is given a
particular thing that does not follow
the target what do you do about it
right
the question yeah yes okay so was it a
meaningful deviation or was it a mistake
now obviously we could provide UX that
what's that that is the question yeah
okay so we could obviously provide UX
for that
could have something which brings in
some kind of dotted line thing and you
know a notifier that says you know
change the indentation question mark and
then then one of the selectors could be
a change all the indentations imagine
that the page came up with a bunch of
dotted lines indicating where the
indentations would move
like to reach your target
sure and imagine that you could for each
one you could click on it to say whether
you want to move that indentation or if
what you see on the page is everything's
hunky-dory except for these couple of
lines that look goofed up then you go
and click those or you might just as
soon as you see two of them you might
just say fix them all because they're
obviously correct yeah or you might say
the whole thing's goofed up I just want
to fix all of them yeah it's thoughts
about um
you
yeah somebody's suggesting we define a
standard annotation style obviously what
our Auto formatter does will be our
standard indentation style but
unfortunately depending on what you're
doing between small piece of code larger
pieces of code there is no uniform
choice well I have long suggested that
you know we're in a position to say you
know you can do what you want but if you
want to hear our recommendation this is
I know donation John we went over this
last time okay there are cases in which
you are doing interactive work where you
want to fill the line there are cases
where you're writing you know systematic
structured code where you want the thing
to be many lines both are useful those
too among other end points you can't
distinguish between on the basis of you
know that they they're both valid things
to do I I'm not conceding the points but
I'm not gonna you know argue about it
either it's you know yeah well I'm not
surprised to lose this argument that
doesn't mean that I agree with okay but
then you should you should show what you
think the ideal indentation is for all
these different cases I mean we've got a
bunch of tests on oh that's a bunch of
work I know but I think you're gonna
discover because I've thought about this
over the course of many years that I
don't think there is a uniform answer I
think it depends on the use case and it
depends on whether the code is steadily
growing and then there's a point at
which you want to flip over and so on I
think it's not so obvious but in any
case okay we're running out of time here
and I want to make sure yes
oh no just as if we were talking about
standardizing on what the auto what the
notebook formatter does one question
that I did have I'll type so like with a
new line you know here all that's added
here is an indenting newline character
and it's a question in my mind what this
you know you know obviously I can't
select it but the space that's to the
left of the - what that is because
that's not easily seen you know just by
by looking at the boxes and so but you
don't know you want to know when you're
putting this into plain text you want to
know what to put that yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay well so we we already do that
I mean if you copy as input texts you
know that's a plain text version of that
which is a copy as input text is the one
that's guaranteed to be semantically
equivalent plain text is not guaranteed
to be good semantically equivalents just
say copy is input text please
[Music]
okay that's your answer yeah yeah okay
so yeah the front end is capable of
producing that for you okay I just want
to come back to one last time the
question of the heuristics for when was
the deviation from the target meaningful
versus a mistake and how you tell that
okay I don't know the answer to that um
but I think that's the question that we
should be I think I I mean think with
some samples of code I think I could
figure out something reasonable I think
it will depend on um yeah I I mean if
you can it's like with handwriting you
know if you see the if you if you just
see the output then it's much harder to
tell what's going on than if you see the
strokes that gave the gave the
handwriting am I making sense
yeah yeah right so in this case if you
see a person hitting these spaces and
new lines and tabs and so on which is
again another degree of freedom we
haven't discussed if you have that data
as well then there's more that you can
say I think I mean that's a big if but
yes oh no no no no stop saying that I
mean look if they are typing this in our
program editor we have that information
do we
well we saw the keystrokes we may not be
collecting it right now but we certainly
could right if they typed it in some
completely other IDE we obviously don't
have that information and you know if we
are providing our indenting rules to
other IDs which is another thing we
should be thinking about and and you
know then well I guess we're just gonna
give him a piece of code that basically
will just format according to our
methods though they can run IDE code and
IDE through it's probably unrealistic to
do anything other than that yeah umm
anyway okay I gotta go umm I really look
forward to seeing the red squiggly lines
and some actual new line based airiness
stuff and hope that that will be soon
and let me just say really quickly that
[Music]
somebody was who was it oh I missed it
in my chat but somebody was asking about
automatic insertion of brackets and such
and I looked it up just so I could say
for them what to watch episode 296 of
live CEO in is where we discussed a
bunch of that's right there and there
may yet be future discussions but that's
that's more relevant to that sort of
question yes and we hope to have really
good solution to that all right and we
didn't let Timothy or any of these folks
say a word here but um next time all
right good stuff thanks everybody talk
to you soon
yep